una iniciativa que ayudará a distender
las relaciones con Cataluña así Pedro
Sánchez del presidente del gobierno
español ha justificado su intención de
reformar el delito de ese edición en una
entrevista televisiva esta noche Sánchez
ha explicado el que mañana viernes su
gobierno presentará en el congreso una
oposición de ley para reemplazar el
delito de sedición pongo uno menos grave
de desórdenes públicos agravados y con
este cambio Pues habrá consecuencias
directas tanto para los líderes
catalanes y ya condenados pero sobre
todo paga los otros líderes que huyeron
en el extranjero como es el caso de
Carles recordemos el ex presidente
Catalán que huyó a Bélgica pues con este
cambio el Carles por ejemplo podría
volver a España arriesgando mucho menos
años de cárcel esta decisión pues
obviamente provocó muchas reacciones por
su parte de aquí el presidente que
Catalán actual se elevó esta decisión
dijo que es un paso más espero por su
parte la oposición de la derecha del
partido popular esta noche acusa a
Sánchez de querer humillaga España con
este pacto a cambio del apoyo de los
catalanes en el congreso queda poco veas
que decidida que les puse si se llega
suficiente o no para que vuelva a España
cinco años justos después de su vida